قد يلاحظ الكثيرون ان بعض الاماكن تحديدا
قد تثير مشاعر الغضب والانزعاج لديها فيما
تشعرك اماكن اخرى بالهدوء الراحه الامر
ربما يتعلق بسيكولوجيه الالوان وهي تلك
التاثيرات التي تظهرها الالوان المختلفه
على نفسيه الفرد وطباعه وبات يعرف استخدام
سيكولوجيه الالوان في التسويق والاعلام
بشكل كبير لقوه تاثيرها على الاشخاص
بالفعل فقد اثبتت العديد من الدراسات
النفسيه ان الالوان لها العديد من
التاثيرات القويه على العواطف والحاله
النفسيه وفي الحضارات القديمه استخدمت
الالوان كادويه وعلاجات مثل الحضاره
الفرعونيه والهنديه القديمه والحضاره
الاغريقيه اما حديثا تطور الامر لتظهر بعض
المراكز التي تستخدم الالوان كعلاج لكن
لنتحدث اولا عن تاثير الالوان المباشره
على الصحه والجسد بحسب احدث الدراسات مع
علاء
للالوان تاثيرات مختلفه وكبيره على
ادميغتنا وصحتنا النفسيه والجسديه فالاحمر
يرفع معدله ضربات القلب وينظم ضغطه الدم
اما التنزه في بيئه خضراء فيخفض معدل
ضربات القلب بمقدار 11 نقطه عن اللون
الاحمر او الابيض كذلك اللون الاصفر يزيد
من معدل التمثيل الغذائي ويحفظ استجابه
الجسم للجوع اللون البرتقالي يحفظ الدوره
الدمويه ويرفع نسبه الاكسجين في الدماغ
اللون الوردي يخفض العدائيه عند الاطفال
بنسبه
54% وتشير الدراسات الى ان 60% من الاشخاص
الذين ينامون في غرفه زرقاء يستيقظون
سعداء اما دهن الغرف باللون الابيض فيعكس
98% من اشعه الشمس ويجعل الغرف تبدو اكبر
اللون البنفسجي هو لون الاطفال
تفضل ادي وفضله
75% من الاطفال
[موسيقى]
الاستوديو تنضم الى سيف لما يسعد صباحك
نورتنا في الاستديو اهلا بك معنا بصباح
العربيه لما نتحدث عن تاثير الالوان على
نفسيات الشخص هل بالفعل لها تاثير هل هو
علم اجتهاد نعم احنا كل واحد في حواليه
مغناطيسي والالوان
فاذا كان اللون الزياده او في نقصان يعمل
عدم توازن للجسم تحسي اذا دخلت على غرفه
معتمه بعثت فتره بدك تطلعي غرفه كثير برضه
بيضه برضه فلازم يكون في توازن بالالوان
نعيشها اها طيب لما انا من محبين لون
الاسود يعني في كل المناسبه صغيره وكبيره
دائما لابسه اسود
طيب خلينا نطب هاي الفكره
شو بتعملي
سلاح ذو حدين بتدل على الغموض وبنفس الوقت
بدل عقده الشخصيه بدلعه انك انت صاحبه
قرار وتتحمل المسؤوليه بس بنفس الوقت بخبي
مشاعر الواحد بالدار وراء وراء
انا اشهد الاثنين
في مقابلات العمل وظائف جدا
انت بتضيق فانت مقابل العمل بدك تعطي فيها
غموض وبنفس الوقت ثقه بالنفس
ملكه بريطانيا
لانه كثير غالي كانوا يصدقوه يعملوا هناك
الوان
بترتاحي بيعطي الثقه بيعطي اللي لابسه انه
انا بشتغل بطريقه من العمل ما بخاف من
اتخذ القرار بل بالعكس بناقش حواليك
الاحمر والاصفر والاحمر والاصفر الاحمر
بعلامه التوقف بالتوقف عن المرور خطر
بيعمل هيك صدمه للجهاز العصبي بتلاحظ انه
بيستخدموه مثلا بالتنزيلات
بالاكلات السريعه حتى توقفت وتطلع علينا
بنصح بالاصفر بس لا الوظائف الابداعيه
اللي فيها طاقه بيدل على اني جاريه وانا
موجود
طيب خلينا نروح كمان نكمل الالوان الثانيه
هي في عندك اخضر وبني مع انه انا مش من
محبين لون البني يعني بيحكي على الاصفر
الاصفر يلا يلا نحكي على اصفر لانه تنبيه
الاصفر برده ولا الوظائف الابداعيه بس للي
ما بحب يلبسه يلبسه بكميه كبيره قليله
يعني ما يلبسه بس يعطي انه انا موجود انا
مبدع انا جريء بني بدك
الاسود صلاح البني بتعرفي الرايه الخشب
القديم علاقه اصاله روتين بس بنفس الوقت
بعطي اني انا ممل انا اثق فيه بس انا كثير
بنزل بالقوانين فمثلا وظائف المحاسبه
الوظائف اللي بدها قوانين واستراكشر
وارقام والتزام الاخضر
بكره طب اذا مثلا حدد مجلولين مع بعض هذه
تلبيق الالوان لازم واحد يعرف اول شيء شو
اللون بيلبق لبشرته عشان هي اللي تبهاش في
اي شيء قريب على البشره لازم يكون مبهج
ويعرف شو الالوان اللي تتناسب مع بعضها
انا الابيض والازرق
الابيض الشفافيه انا زي ما بتشوف جوه زي
ما انا بره وظيفه العمل بالذات اذا فشخ
فشي بقع على العيب البحر